when the ambassador bridge connecting
windsor and detroit was shut by
protesters canadians worried about a
huge economic hit the blockade of the
ambassador bridge has affected about
390 million dollars in trade
each day
the blockade may have affected that
trade but it does not appear to have
stopped it
cross-border trade data recently
released by statistics canada shows that
shippers found a way around the blockade
this graph shows the number of ontario
u.s truck crossings in february and sure
enough truck crossings at the ambassador
bridge ceased for the six day long
blockade but this line shows truck
crossings at all other ontario usa
crossings and it's clear trucking
operators quickly rerouted to other
bridges
what i was a little surprised by was
that we didn't see an effect even for
the
perishable goods the um
you know food fresh food fresh
vegetables which was really an area of
concern as to the fears at the time that
the blockades would cause long-lasting
harm to the canada-us trading
relationship well this auto industry
analyst he's not concerned
us and canada are going to remain strong
for for the near future at the very
least i mean again it's it's 30 years of
progress on integrating these supply
chains
i don't think going to be undone by by
one week on the ambassador bridge still
the public safety minister will make the
case that the blockades caused canadians
to suffer i would just really draw a
bright line between statistics and what
canadians were experienced
experiencing at the border to say
nothing of the fact that here in the
nation's capital the community here was
laid to siege as a result of the
occupation conservatives say the trade
data cannot be ignored i think it
undermines a lot of the government's
arguments in relation to the
justification for imposing the
emergencies act that trade data is going
to get lots of scrutiny and not just
from this special joint committee of mps
and senators but also from the judge
tasked with leading the public inquiry
into the emergencies act and that
inquiry gets underway later this year
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thank you